I'm sitting here with my good friend
Jared Logan who just killed it Jared one
more time for Jared
oh great SATA renege when you were
mentioning shape-shifting I love that
bit yes yeah what is the power that you
would want the most is it you know what
people always get mad at me because I
want stretching you know what I wish I
could defend it but it's just what I
want I want to be and if you're yeah
maybe someone's not a dork like mr.
fantastic like rubberband man I'm gonna
tell you why I think people might be
uncomfortable with it a lot of people go
right they think I'm talking about my
penis when are people going to learn
that I don't do that kind of humor
I do you wanna hire me to do it I will
do it
what about your neck down to penis neck
Oh make fellating yourself yeah
maybe awesome I should have committed it
would have gone by wrong again it would
have gone viral
ah well Jared great said you are a bit
of a super nerd yes I had some of our
nerdier riders know we'll we'll see if
they are we got some either roars for
you okay you ready yes Star Wars or Star
Trek Star Trek one is a fantasy and the
other one's a character-based drama you
guys know which is with unbelievable
pac-man or mrs. pac-man uh I just you
know I think men are better at their
jobs so what if I just suddenly got a
real sexist Elvis that I'm like and with
the war on men in this country has
gotten really out of me ah yikes
no no preference I hate that game I suck
at it I don't like any old video games
they're so hard yeah I like modern
videos where every time you die they're
like try again sport and then you're
fine
you just have to crouch behind a barrel
for five seconds longer do what we might
video games are all like go over here
now talk to this person now hide here
they just tell you what to do I like
that I like that
honky Kong just starts Donkey Kong's
like are you ready too late you're too
late a barrel already do you have no
tutorial yeah Final Fantasy or the movie
first daughter starring Katie Holmes uh
first daughter contrition this one's
gonna be hard yes I know you're a big
Dungeon Master oh I am yeah dungeons or
dragonus well one is sexy and the other
is dragons but I am gonna go I honestly
didn't ago he might know which one was
sexy yeah what if when you saw the end
of the last Hobbit you were like yeah
like oh that's what I like Jared Logan